Build It
Draw It
Play It
Grow It
Fletch It
Train It
Whisk It
Prove It
Beast It
Chase It
Milk It
Drip It
Find It
Thank It
VSauce, Kevin here with some of the coolest something, something, something, something..
this is
BiDiPiGiFiTiWiPiBiCiMiFiDiFiTi
Build It
Draw It
iambetterthanyourkids.com grades the artwork of small children like three year old Kade who attempted to draw her family and received an F.
Play It
This guy is playing this thing
Grow It
The national Peanut board teaches us that unlike most plants the peanut plant flowers above the ground but fruits below ground
Fletch It
Horse Fletcher encouraged fletcherizing, chewing food a 100 times a minute before swallowing and his nick name was 'The Great Masticator.
Train It.
Charlie Hackbarth teaches you how to train your llama on a channel called MyTrainingVideos.
Whisk It.
*whisks intensely*
I'm whisking it.
Prove It.
The Large Hadron Collider hopes to conduct an experiment that will create a miniature black hole.
and prove the existence of parallel universes.
Beast it.
"The Beast" Eddie Hall* broke the world's dead lift record.
and got a hug from Arnold Schwarzenegger.
Chase it.
Notebook babies explains how to make friends while playing a game of "Chase".
"Hey, wanna play chase?"
"Sure."
*giggling*
"You'll never catch meee"
Milk it.
A 2001 study showed dairy cows produce more milk when listening to slow jams.
Specifically songs with less than 100 beats per minute increase milk production by 3 percent.
Freeze it.
You could freeze pancakes and microwave them later and apparently they're still pancakily delicious.
Drip it.
According to the U.S geological survey a leaking faucet wastes one gallon of water after 15,140 drips.
Find it.
The word Vsauce.
Thank it.
And as never, your welcome for making.
Submit nothing to:                                                                                            *42elevinty7@nothingblopblop.com
woof